welcome everyone thank you for joining
me online to celebrate the
accomplishments of the students of the
class of 2020 to the graduating students
I am grateful that we can gather as a
community in this way to honor all that
you have achieved however this is no
replacement for commencement when it is
safe to do so
I will welcome you back to campus to
participate in a traditional Yale
graduation with your classmates in the
meantime your Dean's and I officially
mark your graduation from Yale this year
we recognize the extraordinary work all
of you have completed in your programs
of study we salute your effort your
diligence your talent and your intellect
we also join you in expressing gratitude
for all who have supported you in these
endeavors your families and friends
professors and other members of the Yale
community it is now my great pleasure to
officially confer your Yale degrees to
those who have completed your degree
requirements you have been recommended
by the faculty of your school and your
dean has asked me by my official act to
confer upon you your degree with the
approval of the Yale corporation and by
the authority vested in me that confer
upon you your degree as designated by
your Dean and admit you to all its
rights and responsibilities some of you
will complete your degree requirements
after today when you have been
recommended by the Faculty of your
school and approved by the Yale
corporation your Dean shall ask me by my
official act to confer upon you your
degree by the authority vested in me I
shall confer upon you your degree when
designated by the Dean and shall then
admit you to all its rights and
responsibilities
congratulations to the class of 2020